never before has the youth of America
been called upon to take part in so
gigantic a task as the global war in
which we are engaged never before has
your country so needed your services not
only in various branches of the armed
forces without civilian war workers in
many lives
but to do your part you must be
physically fit for the physical
requirements are most exacting to help
you meet these standards the high school
victory core physical fitness program
has been established by actively
cooperating in this program not only
will you be preparing yourself to serve
your country most efficiently but at the
same time you will be building a sound
foundation for your own good health
happiness and success in the postwar
years to come as an example of the
importance of physical fitness let's
drop in at a Flying V hey take a look
Jim Rice has got to try to shoot landed
Wow its lucky for Jim the instructor
took over
fellas I'd like a few words of Jim
I I guess I was pretty terrible today
yes you were Saddam Jim there's
something I have to tell you that'll be
hard to take what's that buddy there
come times to all of us when we have to
face hard facts unpleasant facts take it
on the chin and grin sometimes bitter
medicine and that's what your up against
right now you're all washed up as far as
ever being a flyer is concerned and
you're just wasting your money taking
lessons am I really that bad yeah it's
awfully hard to take you see I guess
I've always been sort of their minded
the first time I can remember having was
a little airplane she I couldn't have
been more than three or four then how I
loved it mom says I pass up all my new
toys for the little plane wherever I
what I'd carry with me when bedtime
Jamie wouldn't go to sleep unless I had
it with me
when I got bigger I went in for making
model planes and flying them with the
other fellows they had a lot of fun I
learn a lot about how planes fly balance
glide turn bank all those things a few
years later I want to ride in the plane
his first prize in the model plane
contest that road settled it I made up
my mind right then and there that I was
going to be a flyer but I'd never be
happy till I was up in the air handling
the controls all by myself but I knew I
had a problem the problem of getting
mother's consent am I taking flying
lessons she's a grandmas mother in the
world done so much for me the scene dad
died when I was a baby we see supporting
the two of us ever since but her last
one she saw sir I was on it she agreed
to let me take lessons when I was 16
that was nearly a year away gosh that
was along here every day seemed an age I
just couldn't wait you remember I made
arrangements with you about a month
ahead of my first lesson yes I remember
very well yeah and I started well you
know what happened yes and I've never
had a student that was so eager or so
anxious to learn the flyer who tried so
hard in fact that's why I've been giving
you lessons much longer than I should I
wanted to give you every chance I
thought maybe that in time you'd get the
knack of it but are just a waste of time
and money whoo what's the matter with me
I don't know the trouble maybe with your
eyes it might be a good idea to have
another physical examination I'll do it
I'll see dr. Adams tonight
well what's the matter with me dr. your
visual acuity is not up to par can do
something foreign well the first thing
to do is to find the cause that's why
I've been examining you asking so many
questions there must be some focal
infection which has affected your eyes
focal infection yes a source of
infection at some point in the body you
see when a person has a focal infection
the bacteria and other poisons they
produce may enter the bloodstream and be
carried to all parts of the body where
they often set up a secondary infection
in such organs as the heart kidneys all
the joints a common source of such
infection is an abscessed tooth so we'll
check up on that first and that says to
yes dental infection is one of the most
common sources from which bacteria and
the poisons they produce invade the
human body dental health is essential to
physical health oh my teeth are all
right I don't think that could be the
trouble well let's make sure you have
your teeth examined by your family
dentist and x-rays taken okay do you say
so you see this dark area around the end
of the root of this tooth yeah what is
that doctor now that indicates a an
abscessed condition a pocket of
infection hmmm nav says tooth why never
had any trouble with my teeth at least
nothing to speak of mmm sometimes
abscess is formed slowly and cause
little pain these are the most dangerous
because they often go unnoticed for some
time until serious trouble develops
elsewhere in the body then it may be too
late the damage may be done for example
I had a case sent to me the other day of
a girl recently graduated from high
school who was turned down by
company position when she applied for a
job he found she had endocarditis which
is inflammation of the lining membrane
of the heart her x-ray showed a badly
abscessed tooth which her position
believes was the cause of the heart
condition I removed the abscess tooth
but the damage to the heart had already
been done well has my tooth gone too far
I mean have my eyes got so bad it's too
late to do anything well that's
something we can't say definitely at
this time let's go into my office of
course the procedure to remove the
source of infection and do to your youth
there is a possibility that with proper
medical attention the trouble will clear
up but we can't be sure you see Jim it's
a whole lot easier to prevent these
troubles than it is to correct them and
it's a lot easier on your pocketbook to
prevent dental trouble than it is to
correct it you mean I could have
prevented this sure for how by giving
your teeth the attention they used to
get when your mother brought you here
regularly you now just had some good
times together didn't we do you remember
yeah I sure do but when you grew older
he became careless let's see here
say I haven't seen you in a long long
while and now you turn up with an
abscessed tooth and fall division yeah
probably I've been taking care of my
teeth you are sort of Oh many young
people are like that you're so full of
energy and vigor that you never give a
thought to your health until something
happens which could easily have been
prevented what should a fella dude
opportunity to keep his teeth in shape
well the best method I know of is that
recommended by our national organization
the American Dental Association from the
experience of thousands of dentists all
over the country a simple effective
three-way plan has been developed the
first proper just a minute doctor let me
write that down sure first proper diet
now by that we mean a well-balanced diet
that will build and maintain a strong
healthy body a well-balanced nutritive
diet includes milk citrus fruits such as
oranges and grapefruit fresh vegetables
such as carrots cabbage spinach peas and
beans meat eggs and whole grain bread
and another thing to prevent tooth decay
cut down on carbohydrates such as
refined sugar candy jelly pastry and
other highly sweetened foods second
proper brushing keep teeth and gums
clean by brushing them properly after
every meal this removes food particles
that adhere the teeth and that may
promote tooth decay proper brushing also
stimulates the circulation in the
tissues around the teeth it's highly
important that the teeth be brushed
properly just a woman no show you what I
mean
to get the best results use the best
toothbrush obtainable preferably with a
small head and two rows of Bristol Tufts
brush the upper teeth with a downward
motion
and brush the lower teeth with an upward
movement
the top services like this
and the insides of the teeth in this
manner
now the third point regular dental
attention
I'm sure I don't need to emphasize that
to you you mean you could have found
this abscess before it started well not
exactly that Jim but we could have
corrected the dental defect while it was
small and before the decay reached the
pulp or nerve and before it was possible
for Galactus a source of infection for
the rest of the body you know to keep
your mouth and teeth in good condition
they should be examined and cared for by
a dentist at least once every six months
by so doing small defects will be
discovered and corrected before they
become serious at the same time the
teeth can be cleaned stains and
blemishes removed as well as deposits of
tartar which are injurious to gums and
teeth if I've done these things I better
be flying today cash well we'll see what
can be done and it's supporting to come
in again at say Wednesday 11 will give
the teeth another treatment then
and some of the dentist swings into
action to remove the focal infection
which was spreading poison through gem
sister
while the physician cooperates in aiding
nature restore Jim site to normal
then at last comes the critical test a
medical examination by the Civil
Aeronautics Authority examiner
then after Jim has completed eight hours
of dual flight instructions including
recovery from spins and stalls comes the
day of all days in the life of a student
fire that first solo flight
Oh